candace owens and i trend on twitter for
pointing out that harry styles wearing a
dress
isn't acting all that masculine georgia
finds 2600 more votes most of them for
president trump and democrats put more
lockdowns on the table i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today
at expressvpn.com ben okay we'll get to
everything at noozy in one moment but
first there are a thousand reasons why
protecting your home matters to you for
me i want to keep an eye on my kids i
have three
under seven and that means it's hard for
me to keep an eye on all of them at once
this is why i love my ring devices i
also want to know who is at my front
door at all times when somebody rings
the doorbell i can pick up from anywhere
and tell who exactly is outside my house
ring has security products for every
corner of your home inside now best of
all
you can see it all in one simple app
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are right from
your phone if somebody stops by or
something is going on ring will let you
know it's peace of mind anytime knowing
your home is protected whatever you call
home ring has everything you need to
protect it it's the reason
there's a reason why when my wife and i
moved home the first thing she did was
request that we get our ring
devices put in place get a special offer
on the ring welcome kit today at
ring.com that is ring.com
it comes that ring of video doorbell 3
and the chime pro it's the perfect way
to start your ring experience go to
ring.com
ben again that is ring.com go check them
out right now and
you get the special deal on the ring
welcome kit that ring video is level
three and the chime pro it is the
perfect way to start that ring
experience ring.com
ben we begin at this hour with a piece
of good electoral news
our friend burgess owens nfl veteran and
uh and republican has defeated
representative ben mcadams who's the
only democrat in utah's congressional
delegation he conceded his race two
burgess owens on monday that makes owens
the twelfth gop challenger to unseat
his incumbent democratic opponent during
the 2020 election as the republican
party continues to cut into the
democrats house majority this is tim
pierce at daily wire reporting
owens announced that mcadams had
conceded the race in a tweet on monday
evening he said i received a call from
mcadams he expressed appreciation for
the opportunity to serve the utah fourth
district and his commitment to a smooth
transition my sincere thanks to him for
both
thanks to my fellow utahns i am
committed to have an open ear to serve
you thank you
for the opportunity that is a big pickup
that was supposed to be a race that was
fairly easily won
by mcadams and in the late polling
burgess was down and he ended up winning
the race
demonstrating once more that the
republican party wildly outperformed
expectations
in this particular election nancy pelosi
wildly underperformed the democratic
party has a real problem on its hands
regardless of what happens in the
presidential race which again
there's still legal cases outstanding
whatever happens there
democrats have a real problem they have
a real problem so long as republicans
actually
go out and vote in georgia so i'm going
to remind you right now if you're a
republican
you need to give money to david perdue
in georgia and to kelly leflore in
georgia because the last thing that you
want is the specter of the 50 50 senate
with presumably kamala harris presiding
as joe biden's vice president
and breaking ties that is the last thing
you could possibly want checking the
ambitions of the democratic party is a
must at this point
so you need to like there's no time to
rest on your laurels there is no time
to fulminate about stuff that has
already happened instead you need to
focus on what's coming up january 5th
there is a
double election in georgia david perdue
kelly leffler they deserve your support
they deserve your money
they deserve your time the democrats
must be defeated
in those senate races okay meanwhile
speaking of georgia
yesterday 2600 votes were discovered in
floyd county
they had not originally been tallied and
they did reduce the deficit that trump
has
to joe biden in the state according to
the atlanta journal constitution trump
could gain nearly 800 net votes from the
discovered ballot
there were 1643 new votes for trump and
for biden according to the atlanta
journal constitution
the problem occurred because county
election officials did not upload votes
from a memory card
in a ballot scanning machine as
according to gabriel sterling the
state's voting system manager
he called it an amazing blunder he said
the county's election director
director should resign he said it's not
an equipment issue it's a person not
executing their job properly
this is the kind of situation that
requires a change at the top of their
management side
the previously uncounted votes were cast
during in-person early voting
at the floyd county administrative
building which includes the county
elections office
said luke martin chairman of the floyd
county republican party over half of the
5 000 printed out ballots cast on an
optical scanner were not initially
recorded
martin said it's very concerning this
doesn't appear to be a widespread issue
i'm glad the audit revealed it it's
important that all votes
are counted the ballots will be
rescanned and tabulated before the
results are finalized on friday said
state elections director chris harvey
he said you want every vote counted
right the first time that is one of the
goals of the audit to identify problems
all the votes will be uploaded the
results will be
what they are so yeah the the state is
insisting that the audit
is exactly what found it anyway that it
wasn't trump putting pressure that found
these additional
votes eric erickson tweeted out about
this he said this is a scanner
malfunction it wasn't a machine error
per se a human error in scanning balance
but most counties still align
identically with the machine count at
this point
right he has an entire thread about
dominion voting systems in georgia
and he uh he says that he talked with
the georgia secretary of state about
signature issue he says that georgia
verified signatures for absentee ballot
applications not just the ballots
themselves the applications were matched
with both the voters driver's license
and their voter registration card
and so george has actually been
attempting to verify that people
requested the ballots legally it's not
just they filled out the ballots legally
but that they requested the ballots
legally apparently lindsey graham asked
specifically about this this
pissed off the georgia secretary of
state who then suggested openly that
lindsey graham wanted to exclude legal
ballots
it turns out that that's not true uh but
according to the
the guy's name is raffensberger this was
reported by mediaite in their
conversation graham questioned
raffensberger about the state's
signature matching law and whether
political bias could have prompted poll
workers to accept ballots with
non-matching signatures according to
raffensberger graham also asked whether
rathensburger had the power to toss all
male ballots in counties
fans have higher rates of non-matching
signatures according to raffensberger
raffenberger said he was stunned that
graham appeared to suggest that he find
a way to toss illegally
cast a ballot that is not what graham
says graham says no no i was just asking
if there is a way
to toss ballots that are not legally
requested or in which there is no way to
verify the matching signature
in any case the process is working as
the process should work
eric erickson points out that all claims
of dead people voting in georgia have
thus far been debunked he says no dead
person
has actually voted in georgia he says
contrary to claims about dominion voting
systems the hand count in georgia
aligned perfectly with the machine count
there could not have been hacked
machines
in georgia altering votes for joe biden
as according to eric erickson
uh who does a show down there on wsb
obviously
uh the biden camp meanwhile is uh
demonstrating
full scale what the real corruption in
this election was and it has very little
to do with the voting systems again we
have legal cases that are proceeding
we have allegations for sidney powell
the lawyer for president trump should
have suggested that she is about to
release the kraken
which of course is a very colorful
phrase and here's my view of this go
ahead and release it seriously like
we're all waiting like republican
democrat everybody's waiting the
democrats are waiting because they want
to say that you're lying
and republicans are waiting because the
evidence would actually be really great
at this point you're gonna make big
allegations like that
then it's time to actually release all
the evidence that you've got not do
interviews about it release the i mean
it's not like we have a huge timeline
here i mean we're gonna get
states certifying their election results
as early as the end of this week or
early next week so like
now would be the time to release the
kraken if you are going to do this but
the real corruption
in the election is perfectly obvious as
i've said from the beginning the real
corruption
in this election is the media the media
simply refused to cover
anything they did not want to cover and
they just didn't cover it
according to sam stein reporting about
the
daily beast the daily beast had a piece
all about joe biden online
sam stein who reports for the daily
beast now he says according to biden
campaign metrics online chatter about
the hundred biden story during the
elections last week
was greater than it was around hillary's
emails during the last month of 2016.
the difference it never spilled over
into mainstream outlets
oh you think oh you think so the fact is
that you are now bragging the biden
campaign is now bragging that they were
able
to suppress information that was bad for
joe biden that mainstream media decided
to do the dirty work of the biden
campaign
by not allowing well-reported
and factual stories to emerge into the
public view because mainstream media
never jumped on it mainstream media just
decided it was more important to defeat
trump than to report truly reported
stories
i mean we all knew this was the case the
fact is
that the biden campaign and the media
are one and the same you can see it
right joe biden is now doing these press
conferences and every question in the
press conference is
how wonderful are you joe biden we are
back to the obama era in the obama era
the press walked around holding drool
cups for barack obama now we are back
there and they are walking around
holding drool cups for joe biden's which
both of them are drawing
drooling biden because he's falling
apart in the media because they're
drooling over joe biden and then trying
straining to get themselves enthusiastic
about kamalaires which is uh good luck
with that gang
according to the daily beast fearing a
redux of the disastrous end of campaign
implosion of hillary clinton
the team go further into the research
what they found was more assuring while
the hunter biden story had taken off on
facebook youtube and various right-wing
sites
it had not crossed over into mainstream
outlets the campaign's internal polling
meanwhile showed that voters largely
weren't persuaded by it
the wildfire ended up being mostly smoke
but even so it provided the biden
campaign with yet another reminder about
the perils that social media platforms
present to democrats
as they traverse the modern political
landscape let it be known
this is why democrats are attempting to
quash
these social media companies democrats
would love nothing better than for
social media companies to act
as their suppressive wing stopping
stories from trending
preventing people from disseminating
information they do not like
right that is the future of battle that
is the informational battle that we are
going to be about to wage in this
country
the platforms are now being perverted by
democrats they are being threatened by
democrats that if they do not suppress
information democrats don't like then
democrats themselves will go in and
break up these major corporations or
regulate those corporations and these
corporations
facebook twitter youtube they are
responding predictably by catering to
the left
and hoping for the goodwill of the right
they're responding by suppressing
exactly the information the left wants
and hoping that the rights focus in on
free markets and free speech
will prevent the right from siding with
the left in regulating these companies
they can only count on the kindness of
people who are batting
where you are clubbing about the ears
for so long and there will be a breaking
point here with the right
right there's going to come a point
where the right says to these social
media companies
listen we're like batman at the end of
batman begins
right we we're not gonna kill you but we
don't have to save you and that is the
direction in which all of this is moving
okay in just a minute
we are getting to the healing of the
democratic party and we have been told
that there's a healing time lots of
healing
going on cultural healing we'll get to
that healing in just one second it does
not appear that a lot of healing is
going on
first let us talk about your sleep
quality so i'll admit my baby woke me up
at 5 30 this morning it was not
fantastic but
between the time i went to bed and the
time that my child awoke me i did sleep
well why because i was on a helix sleep
mattress
helix sleep they make a mattress just
for you it is personalized to you they
have a quiz
it takes just two minutes to complete
and they match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or a
firm bed with helix there's no more
confusion and no more compromising
helix sleep it's rated the number one
mattress by gq and wired magazine
cnn has called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just head
on over to helixleep.com
ben take their two minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life they've got a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights at risk free they'll even pick it
up for you if you don't love it but you
absolutely will helix is offering up to
200 bucks off all mattress orders for
our listeners get up to 200 bucks off
at helixsleep.com again that is
helixsleep.com go check them out right
now you need a high quality mattress so
your sleep quality is better
why not have it personalized to you just
like everything else in your life we
live in a time of personalization
personalize the mattress that you're
sleeping on eight hours a night go check
them out right now helixsleep.com and
get to 200 bucks off when you use that
code
helixsleep.com one final note
when it comes to voting in georgia and
media bias so the media have been trying
out this narrative ever since the
election
that stacey abrams won the state of
georgia for joe biden
nope nope they just keep trying to make
fetch happen
and fetch is not happening guys you
can't you can keep saying this over and
over and over
but fetch just not as thin is not a
thing according to nate cone at the new
york times
georgia is the first state where they
now have a fully updated vote history it
shows the black share of the electorate
falling to its lowest levels
since 2006. so the black share of the
electorate
black share of all voters actually
dropped precipitously
from 2018 to 2020. the black share of
the electorate in georgia
it was about 29 it dropped all the way
down to 27
this time around okay but we keep
hearing that it was stacey abrams
registering black voters all over the
state that drove joe biden to victory
no it was not it was the suburbs it was
white suburban women did not vote for
donald trump
and so georgia went the wrong way for
donald trump in the current vote count
okay but to me it's amusing to watch the
media continue to prop up stacey abrams
as a thing
she's not a thing she never was a thing
she lost her gubernatorial race by 50
000 votes in that state
and then she went around claiming she
was governor of georgia the dnc
touted her as the elected governor of
georgia after losing by 50 000 votes
and then if you say to the media by the
way you know you guys keep feeding
stacey abrams like f-e-t
injury you keep feeding stacey abrams
you keep praising her
even though she continues to maintain
that she was ripped off and deprived of
her gubernatorial seat in georgia
at the same time that she's going on tv
claiming that donald trump is a whiner
hey you got this is you guys you guys
keep doing this like no no no you're not
allowed to talk about that so
just a data point there stacey abrams
was not in fact the person
who drove georgia out of the republican
lane in the presidential race says
please
stop trying to make stacey abrams happen
it's not a thing okay meanwhile
the democrats have proclaimed it's a new
era of healing and unity right this is
joe biden's line joe biden
after he uh after he gave his quasi
victory address obviously precipitously
because not a single state has yet been
declared
joe biden came out and he said that he's
all for unity it's time for america to
come together and it's time to heal
so i have a question at what point is he
gonna say to his own party guys you need
to stop being jackasses
hey seriously that'd be good we talked
about this yesterday we had rioting
and we had people beating each other up
blm antifa
in washington dc during this trump rally
over the weekend
and members of joe biden's own party are
are going around basically suggesting
that everybody who disagrees with them
is a member of the kkk so at some point
is joe biden going to calm the waters on
his own side
see there used to be a thing called a
sister soldier moment back during the
1992 campaign there was a little-known
rapper named sister soldier
and she made some rather racially
charged comments
and bill clinton kind of picked her out
of a hat because he wanted to make this
move
and he he proceeded to make her famous
by saying that this sort of rhetoric is
not acceptable and not okay
and that was his move to the moderate
lane bill clinton's
okay well when does joe biden actually
move to the moderate lane by chatting
people on his own side for castigating
everybody who disagrees with them as a
clan member so ilhan omar
truly a terrible human being ilhan omar
is a rabid anti-semite
um there there are credible allegations
that she has repeatedly funneled a bevy
of money to her to her boyfriend or at
least her boyfriend's firm
in violation of campaign finance law
we'll check out those allegations but
those allegations have been floating
around for quite a while and seem to be
mounting
in any case ilhan omar the person who
poses on the cover of magazines with
nancy pelosi
before declaring that for the jews it's
all about the benjamins she says that
donald trump rallies are like clan
rallies i can feel all the peace in the
healing can't you so much peace and
healing happening
to speak about me at
every single rally didn't really matter
where he was
uh sometimes multiple times in a day
um as he had held his clan rallies
throughout the country
other clan rallies now you see when tens
of thousands of people show up for
rallies for donald trump
those are clan rallies which is strange
because there are a lot of people of
color at those at those particular
supposed clan rallies which
don't actually seem a lot like clan
rallies okay but it's not just ilhan
omar the media obviously
believe this deeply as well brian
williams
suggests that trump voters are tyranny
curious ryan williams on msnbc
it's trump voters who are interested in
tyranny which is weird because i keep
hearing from the democratic party that
they want to run nearly every aspect of
my life but it's trump voters who are
tyranny curious here's brian williams
fake journalist
as you look at home from there and when
you come home
on your next visit do you view it as a
changed country because
millions of people uh decided maybe over
time like the frog boiling experiment
to become at least tyranny curious
see you see trump voters are so now we
know from ilhan umar that they are clan
members
now we know from brian williams the
trump voters are tyranny curious and we
also know from whoopi goldberg that
republicans literally don't care if you
die
they don't care at all they want you to
die now this has been a line democrats
have been using ever since paul ryan
they literally cut an ad i believe it
was back in 2010
in which paul ryan was like throwing an
old lady off a cliff or something
in any case here's whoopi goldberg
suggesting that republicans don't care
if you die i can feel the healing
can you feel the healing power of love
happening right now
i feel it i think it's it's all warm and
cuddly and here here's will be goldberg
saying that the republicans just want
people to die
that's what all of this is and when you
go into
vote in georgia remember this is the
party
that doesn't care if you drop dead
because you can't believe
clearly they know what has to happen and
they're not doing it
weird because uh i i'm reliably informed
that half of the
democratic legislature of california
just traveled over to maui
for a conference and then traveled back
and didn't quarantine so yeah no
it's by the way a lot of people died in
new york and new jersey and but it's the
republicans it's
always the republicans okay in just a
second we're going to get to the
gaslighting of the american people
because at root
so much of what's going on is the
gaslighting of the american people it's
an attempt to get you
to shut up there's a process that is
used to get you to shut up particularly
if you're culturally conservative that
we need to talk about okay we'll get to
that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that
right now guns are flying off the
shelves they have been flying off the
shelves for a while
i wonder why might it be the fostering
of chaos in america's major cities
might it be the fact that the media and
the democratic party are fully willing
to overlook violence so long it is
violence that aligns with their
political world view well whatever your
reason
you might be looking for a gun and when
the framers wrote the constitution the
first thing they did was to make sacred
your right
to keep and bear arms right this is the
thing that they they were focused on
at heart they knew that all your other
rights are protected by that particular
right owning a rifle is a heavy
responsibility building rifles is no
different
bravo company manufacturing builds a
professional grade product which is
built to combat standards that's because
bcm believes the same level of
protection should be provided to every
american
regardless if they're a private citizen
or a professional the people at bcm
assume when a rifle leaves their shop
it can be used in a life or death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or soldier overseas
so every component of a bcm rifle is
hand assembled and tested by americans
they understand that you're not buying a
gun because you really want to go target
shooting you need it in case god forbid
you need it
so this is why you should check out
bravo company manufacturing head on over
to bravo company
mfg.com you can discover more about
their products special offers
and upcoming news that is
bravocompanymfg.com if you need more
convincing find out even more about bcm
and the awesome folks who make their
products at youtube.com
bravo company usa okay so
there's a gaslighting project that is
that is happening in real time
the gaslighting project is designed to
shut you up you yes you
right whether it is abigail schreier
writing a book on why it is bad to
transition
young children from male to female
through hormone therapy
or whether it is matt iglesias right
who's just a mainstream
left guy basically leaving his own
publication there's an attempt to shut
down debate there's an attempt to shut
you up it is particularly directed at
conservatives
okay the there's a process that the left
has been using for quite a while and it
is
quite effective process so let me
describe the process of getting you
personally to shut up because i know
that you felt this in your regular life
right you felt this from your peers you
feel this from your bosses you feel this
from the media okay so here is the
process the process goes like this it's
basically a three-step process
the first the first move is for people
to tell you that if you voice your
opinion you're being not nice
see what the left understands about
conservatives is that conservatives
generally
value decency they generally value
politeness right conservatives tend to
believe that decency
and niceness and politeness these are
virtues these are good qualities
now it's very easy to shift from being
nice and being polite and being decent
into a belief that this means being
inoffensive right because if you're nice
typically that means that you're not
offending
anybody right you're being a nice person
that means that you're not offending
anybody but there is a difference
between
being decent and being and being
inoffensive
there's a wide difference in
conservative philosophy sometimes you
actually have to chide people when they
do the wrong thing
it's actually a biblical maxim is that
you're not supposed to you're not
supposed to ignore it when your friend
sins
you're supposed to chide him and correct
him but it is very easy to fall into the
trap because it's seductive
of basically saying that i'm a nice guy
and so i'm never going to say anything
offensive and so what the left does is
they simply deem
anything that you are saying offensive
and thus you have you have now violated
the niceness principle you're no longer
nice
you're no longer decent you're no longer
kind right they understand that you want
to be kind and you want to be nice and
so if they act offended
that's a way of shutting you up right
it's a way of saying your principles are
offensive to me so you should be quiet
okay then they push even further okay
because you might say well
yes you're offended but your offense is
really not the main thing the question
is is what i'm saying true or is it not
right you might say like i do facts
don't care about your feelings and it's
not
mean to simply state a fact so what the
leftist
instead does is they conflate offense
and harm right this is the second step
of shutting you up
the first step is you're not being nice
you say well it's not about niceness or
not niceness
there's nothing mean about saying
something true they say no no it's not
just that you're being offensive
and that you should be inoffensive it is
that you are harming me right they
conflate offense with harm
right you are now harming me you're
saying something that harms me and
therefore you should shut up
because it's one thing for you to be not
nice it's another thing for you to be
harmful
and cruel and this is why the left spins
up every offense into a deep-seated harm
this is where you get the language of
microaggressions on college campus right
i say something that is factual and now
you get very offended and you don't just
say that you are offended
you say that i have harmed you i've
aggressed you i've done something that
infringes
on your ability to see yourself the way
you want to see yourself and this
is an actual harm to you it's an
emotional harm to you and therefore i
should shut up i violated the non-harm
jsmill principle
okay so step one was you're not being
nice step two is you're actively harming
me
so you need to be quiet okay and that
brings us to step three right step three
is silence is violence
right step three so he went from you
should be quiet to be nice two you
should be quiet because you're harming
me too
you being quiet is the problem now
when folks on the left say silence is
violence what they don't mean is we want
you to speak freely what they mean is we
want you to speak and repeat exactly
what we are about to tell you and if you
do not mirror our preference if you're
not celebrate our preference if you not
celebrate
our political points of view this means
that you are a bad person
right and now you're being not nice
you're being harmful
silence is violence you are actually
acting in a violent way by refusing to
go along with what we are saying
it's the seinfeld aids ribbon episode
right if you just refuse to wear the
ribbon that in and of itself is the
crime
because you are not repeating you're not
joining the cause this is the ibramex
candy routine where
it's not enough to not be racist you
have to be anti-racist you have to
repeat all of the bullcrap that ibrahmax
can dispuese
in order for you to be considered
anti-racist so we went all the way from
we don't want you to express your
viewpoint to we want you to positively
express
our viewpoint so that is the process and
the process always begins with you're
not being nice
okay so you're not being nice that first
step
usually is implicated when the left does
something controversial
so left has this gaslighting thing okay
gaslighting is this phenomenon
it comes from an old movie from the
1940s with charles boye and ingrid
bergman
the the movie is about a woman who is
being driven crazy by her husband he
wants her to commit suicide so he can
take her inheritance and so he
changes the the light on the gas light
every night and then tells her he has
not done so right to drive her nuts
that's what gaslighting means gas
lighting is where you know something is
going on
but people around you are telling you
that it's not going on right that's what
gaslighting is so the left
engages in this gas lighting the way
that they engage in the gas lighting is
they do something controversial
they say something controversial they
push a controversial point of view they
celebrate this controversial point of
view
and then if you say no i i disagree they
say ah you're not being nice
you're being offensive you're causing
harm right that's a
you're a bad person how could you how
could you
you get this phenomenon a lot in for
example los angeles
the the kind of attention
attention-seeking behavior that you see
very often and then if you pay attention
to the behavior they go
why are you paying attention why are you
because you asked me to pay attention
right this is all leading up to a
discussion of harry styles by the way if
you're not aware where this is going
there's a there's a thing that happens
very often in places like l.a where you
walk into a you walk into a coffee bean
and the barista has pink hair and a ring
on the nose and a ring on the ear and a
chain connecting both
connecting all the way to the other ear
and then
you you kind of look for a moment too
long and the person looks at you and
says what are you looking at
well it feels like you were seeking
attention when you decided to connect a
chain from your ear to your nose to your
other ear
like that that's an actual overt sign
that you might want to like your hair is
shockingly bright pink i feel like you
might want some attention there
and then it's like why are you paying
attention why are you paying attention
well that's why we're paying attention
but paying attention is not the sin if
you want to act that way it's a free
country you can act that way but paying
attention to having opinions is not in
fact a violation of the niceness
principle
nor is it an excuse to silence other
people okay this brings us to the harry
styles issue we'll get to that in just
one moment
but first let's talk about the fact that
as dudes a lot of your identity might be
wrapped up in your hair not your pink
hair it might be wrapped up
in like actually having hair and as men
age they tend to bald okay this is just
one of the
realities of life male pattern baldness
is a genetic thing
and most men start losing hair in their
in their 20s and
in their early 30s well now there's
keeps two out of three dudes are going
to experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
you just have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered directly to your
home
they make it easy they deliver your
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor visits
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there you might have tried them
before probably never for this price
keeps treatments typically take between
four to six months to see results it's
important to act fast the sooner you
start using keeps the more hair you will
save find out why keeps has more five
star reviews than any of its competitors
and more than one hundred thousand men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication
keeps treatments start at just 10 bucks
a month plus for a limited time you can
get your first
month for free it is quick it is easy it
saves you a lot of money and it can save
your hair which is a very very useful
thing if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
bend receive your first month of
treatment for free that is k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash ben
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash ben okay so
this brings us to the vogue photo shoot
with harry styles
so this first hit my attention yesterday
when candace owens tweeted about it
vogue magazine featured harry styles so
i the only reason i know harry styles
honestly is because he was in dunkirk
like i i've never heard his music i
don't care about him i honestly as i say
like my only experience like knowing who
he is is that he was in a christopher
nolan film
but he did this photo shoot with vogue
in which he dressed garishly in a bunch
of women's clothing and he looks like an
idiot
hey let's just put that out there
straight up front he looks like a
okay because men wearing women's dresses
typically that's
like there's a reason that bugs bunny
plays it for comic effect
when he puts on a dress to fool elmer
fudd right it's inherently funny we're
not talking here about a guy who's
identifying as transgender and has
gender dysphoria or something this is a
this is just
a regular dude putting on a dress okay
and
can we use like a bit of common sense
here that that's at least strange
it's something different and by the way
vogue knows that it's strange and
something different
see here's where the gas lighting comes
in vogue treats this as groundbreaking
and wonderful
now in your regular life if somebody
that you
let's say that you're a married woman
and your husband comes through the door
wearing one of your gowns
would your first reaction be i love how
you're bending gender norms honey
fabio i asked our our hair and makeup
person fabiola
about this and her reaction i thought
was it was on the mark
she said my husband walked through the
door wearing one of my dresses i would
punch him
yeah okay fair enough fair enough but in
any case
i'm not saying that anybody who wears a
dress should be punched i'm just saying
what fabiola said okay i'm just
reporting to you the fact
in any case harry styles is wearing
these
bizarre garrosh outfits and we are told
this is very brave incredibly brave
it's not just that he put on these
outfits by the way we know that this is
playing with stereotypes and redefining
masculinity right that is the goal here
it is the overt goal
because if this were just about you know
i like to wear creative clothing he'd
put on like a panda bear suit or
something it's him walking around in
like a finding nemo costume
but he's not he's wearing a dress and
the reason he's wearing a dress is
because he's trying to violate
preconceived notions about masculine
okay and vogue makes this perfectly
clear
so we are told by various interview
subjects that styles cross-dressing
represents quote the image of a new era
of the way that a man can look
okay and that the pop star is quote
redefining what it can mean to be a man
with confidence
uh you see the most confident men are
the ones who wear dresses the more
confident you are in your masculinity
the more
you can afford to be not masculine in
fact the highest form of masculinity is
to completely castrate yourself that
would actually be the highest form of
masculinity
because if you do that that shows how
masculine you are because you had to
have balls to take them off right i mean
that really is the highest form of
masculinity is to do things that make
you as
little masculine as humanly possible
that's that's the mark of manhood
okay the actress olivia wilde says quote
i hope that this brand of confidence as
a male that harry has
truly devoid of any traces of toxic
masculinity is indicative of his
generation and therefore the future of
the world
i think he's in many ways championing
that spearheading that it's pretty
powerful
kind of extraordinary to see someone in
his position redefining what it can mean
to be a man
with confidence oh that's okay so first
of all it's not just devoid of toxic
masculinity is devoid of any masculinity
okay this is not there's nothing
masculine about this in fact the whole
point here
is to rob masculinity of its masculine
side right that is the entire point the
point is to redefine masculinity to now
include doing feminine things
if it were just about a man being
confident to wear what he wants to wear
then he'd be out there like borat in a
banana hammock or something right but
that's not what he's doing
right what he's doing instead is he's
putting on a dress because he's trying
to mix up the stereotypes of male and
female
so this is an attention seeking behavior
right this is harry styles with the pink
hair and the nose ring and the
and the chain going from ear to ear
right that's that's what this is and it
is overtly a political attempt to shift
the definition of masculinity
okay i'm not making this up don't be
gaslit by the left it says
why are you making a big cause you made
a big deal out of it you don't get to
crash a car and then when i look at the
car crash say hey look there's a car
crash you go there's no car crash what
are you even looking at
you guys are the ones making a political
point out of a dude wearing a dress and
i am saying i think that your political
point is stupid
because it is stupid okay so that
gaslighting attempt is really irritating
so we'll get to what candice had to say
and then what i had to say about this in
just a moment because
there is a broader point to be made if
the left is going to now decline
is now going to claim that being a man
wearing a dress is the highest form of
masculinity because you have shed toxic
masculinity
and then i say i think that this is a
perversion of masculinity because
feminizing males
is not the goal of being masculine
masculine and feminine have definitions
it is good for men to be masculine
it is a good thing to train boys to be
masculine
and then for masculinity to be tempered
by civilization right for all of human
history
masculinity unbound has had very very
negative effects right masculinity
unbound
from anything like responsibility the
aggressive instinct that is inherent in
males generally speaking
unbound from civilization and civilizing
influences and traditional
judeo-christian morality has had dire
dire effects okay but masculinity
has also done incredibly great things
for the world assertiveness
has meant progress assertiveness has
meant growth
assertiveness has meant defense of
family and hearth and home
and has meant prosperity right
masculinity is a good thing for
civilizations
and civilizations that decide to
essentially defenestrate masculinity are
going to bear some pretty ill effects
now if you make that point the left says
you have to shut up you're not being
nice right now you're being offensive
so do something outrageous somebody else
comments on the outrageous thing you
should shut up
you don't don't comment on the
outrageous thing celebrate the
outrageous thing
or silence is violence we're going to
get to the actual analysis of this
particular issue in a second because
masculinity is important
what the left wants to do is rewrite
masculinity they do not want
to to fight toxic masculinity they want
to fight masculinity itself
right being a man is a bad thing unless
you are
treating manhood as actually acting in
feminine ways because feminine and
masculine have definitions we'll get to
that
in one second confusion is the goal here
because if they were to make this
argument straight up that men should act
like women
that men should don dresses and act just
like women everybody would realize how
stupid this is so instead they've
decided to deliberately confuse the
terminology
first they say masculine and feminine
are categories true
and then they say feminine and masculine
are not categories and if you point out
their categories
then it's because you're some sort of
bigot so it's all self-contradictory
crap we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
are looking for great sleep quality it's
not just enough to have your healing
sleep mattress
you also need to have an excellent set
of sheets
what do millions of americans and three
former u.s presidents have in common
they all agree that bowl and brand
sheets are the softest most comfortable
pure organic cotton sheets on earth
bowl and branch cotton is rain fed
pesticide free and carries the highest
organic certification which is why it is
so soft
because they work with family owned
mills all over the world who expertly
weave every set of bowl and brand sheets
with the highest levels of craftsmanship
it is quality you can feel the moment
you open the box i love my bowling brand
sheets in fact i love them so much that
we had
other sheets we took all of them through
the mail bowling branch sheets literally
ruined all of the other sheets for my
family we had to get bowling branches
for everybody because they are just
that good since they sell direct to you
bowling brand sheets start at just 160
they are thousand dollar quality sheets
for a fraction of the price plus you can
sleep on them for a month risk-free
right now you'll get 50 bucks off any
set
of sheets at bullanbranch.com with promo
code ben shapiro spelled b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code ben
shapiro for 50 bucks off
bowlingbranch.com promo code ben shapiro
restrictions may apply
200 bucks order minimum see
bullandbranch.com for details okay we're
going to get to more of this in a second
the gas lighting which does have again
broader ramifications for our public
discussions
we'll get to that in just a second first
if you're not already disgusted by the
mainstream media you absolutely should
be
it is obvious that they were worth 10
points to joe biden in that election
cycle they lied about every single
narrative they continue to lie about
every single narrative
just because cnn msnbc even fox news
declares something that doesn't
necessarily make the narrative true
it means that media outlets push a
narrative that very often they find
beneficial not only that the media has
already shifted from demonizing trump
and his supporters to flattering joe
biden and kamal harris before they've
even taken office if you watched
joe biden's presser yesterday the media
basically just acted as sycophantic lap
dogs so we are back to the obama era
if you're sick of the media feeding you
a narrative replace your cable and your
new subscriptions with the daily wire
we have big plans for the next four
years it starts today candace owens new
york times best-selling author founder
of the blexit foundation
is joining the daily wire where she will
be launching a brand new show with us
early next year we'll also be launching
an entertainment channel like with
actual movies and tv
a new investigative journalism team
building partnerships with like-minded
content creators like prageru
their entire show library will be
available to dailywire.com members by
the end of the year we are building up
an alternative
to the mainstream media a replacement
for the mainstream media join us
because not only are you helping us
you're also helping to destroy the
legacy media that have crafted this
entire
narrative around the idea that you're a
bad person right now just to show you
we're serious we're offering 25
off all memberships of code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe members get our articles ad
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
exclusive readers past content available
only to daily wire members
if you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for live stream
discussions with our hosts and an
amazing online community you also get
not one but two leftist years tumblers
with your membership as well as early
sometimes exclusive access to new daily
wire products so remember that's 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com subscribe replace
the legacy media with daily wire you're
not going to regret it you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so a couple of obvious stipulations
up front men have always
done cross-dressing there have always
been some segment of men who cross-dress
very often it was played for comedy and
the entire premise of some like it hot
is that it is funny
when men cross-dress that is not what
the harry styles photo shoot is about
right there have been pop stars who've
done this before david bowie wearing a
dress they always look like idiots by
the way you always look ridiculous but
the whole point is to be transgressive
right but what we are seeing with the
vogue article is not just an attempt to
be transgressive obviously it's an
attempt to redefine masculinity itself i
mean this is overt in the article i'm
not making it up
i already read you the segment's from
the vogue magazine article okay so my
friend candace owens tweets out quote
there is no society that can survive
without strong men the east knows this
in the west the steady feminization of
our men at the same time that marxism is
being taught to our children is not a
coincidence
it is an outright attack bring back
manly men
okay i i'm not sure what exactly is
controversial about this that
masculinity is a good and important
thing when channeled properly
it requires men to defend family it
requires men to provide
it requires men to channel their
aggressive instincts towards defense of
values and civilization
that that is it requires assertiveness
masculine aristotle talks about
masculinity in exactly these sorts of
terms harvey mansfield has an excellent
book called manliness
all about masculinity and what
distinguishes it from femininity
now it's not that the left doesn't
acknowledge these are qualities the left
fully acknowledges the qualities of
masculinity
and femininity right which is why they
suggest that there are a wide variety of
genders
because they suggest that a man can be
very feminine and this actually makes
him a woman
right so they agree that this means that
there is such a thing as masculinity and
femininity
they then just suggest that men should
act like women right that men should
masculinity
should be made more feminine and candace
disagrees she says that when you make
men
more feminine when you suggest that men
need to be like women they need to wear
dresses right that this
undermines some fundamentally good thing
about men
in the same way that if you said that
women ought to act like men it's funny
if you say
that women ought to act more like men
this is considered sexist because it
actually is sexist but if you say that
men ought to act more like women this is
considered progressive in forward
thinking
the attempt to feminize men is ongoing
on the left
okay so this prompted me to defend
candace's comment and i said this is
perfectly obvious
anyone who pretends it is not a
referendum on masculinity for men to don
floofy dresses and then be celebrated by
magazines like vogue is gaslighting you
masculinity and femininity are
categories
they exist right some behavior is more
masculine like punching people in the
face
some behavior is more feminine like
wearing floofy dresses right there there
are many different forms of masculinity
and femininity
the most important form of femininity is
bearing and rearing children
okay that is something that is endemic
biologically to
female mammals of all species is it
bearing and rearing their young
right and it is endemic for men and
males of all mammalian species to be
more aggressive right these are just
biological realities to pretend that
they are social constructs entirely is
completely idiotic and anti-scientific
and anti-evidentiary
masculinity and femininity do exist and
not only that how does this tie into the
whole dress conversation
outward indicators of masculinity and
femininity exist in nearly every human
culture
right we train little boys to be
masculine and we train little girls to
be more feminine we try to breed out of
them the toxicity
of masculinity or the toxicity of
femininity we try to use civilization to
civilize children
but boys are boys and girls are girls
right and these are important things
boys ought to be allowed to act like
boys girls ought to be allowed to act
like girls
boys are taught to be more masculine in
virtually every human culture this is
not a western-centered thing
boys are taught to be more masculine in
virtually every human culture
because the role of men is not in fact
always the same as the role of women
there can be crossover men and women can
do very many of the same jobs
but to suggest that men and women are
identical and they are widgets created
by social conditioning is just bull crap
it is not true it is not scientifically
true
it is it is a violation of actual
scientific biology there are differences
between men and women on the broad range
that does not mean
that there's not again men who act more
like women or women who act more like
men they're not more effeminate men and
more masculine women right all of that
exists but the fact that there is a
spectrum of human biology does not mean
there are not polls there are indeed
polls
right as in p-o-l-e-s there are polls
masculine and feminine
the left knows this in fact the point of
the harry styles photo shoot
is to violate those polls right is to
feminize masculinity
olivia wilde says it herself the idea is
to rethink masculinity as
femininity to feminize men to get rid of
toxic masculinity
by suggesting that men should act like
women otherwise it would not be headline
worthy for harry styles to put on a
dress
but if it were just about harry styles
again playing with dress the way he says
that
it is and he would have dressed up as a
giant baby in a diaper with like a with
a pacifier right like
he's not doing that he's dressing up in
a women's gown because he's attempting
to make a point which is that men
should be more like women right and the
left knows this
they know this they openly say that
gender is both important and socially
constructed
right they say that gender is actually
inborn but also socially constructed
right they want it both ways they say
that gender is a social construction
and that and that it's that femininity
is just
men cramming down the patriarchy on
women but they will also say
that gender which is the manifestation
of
biology right but they don't think so
they think the gender is just your
femininity or masculinity
is actually inborn and inherent to you
so they say that a man can be a woman
even though there's no biological
underpinning so gender is real but also
it's socially constructed it's all
self-contradictory but
let's assume for a second the honesty of
some folks on the left who
at least acknowledge that femininity and
masculinity exist they also have
indicators outward indicators
dress has been for virtually all time
and in virtually all cultures an outward
indicator which is why the bible
explicitly says that it is against
cross-dressing for example
okay but in virtually every culture men
and women dress differently
this does not mean that all men dress
the same and all women in all cultures
dress the same
it means that in every culture there is
a distinction between how men dress and
how women dress the stupidest form of
the argument that i saw yesterday online
was well in scotland they were kilts
hmm that means that a man in america
wearing a skirt a floofy skirt
is the same as a man in scotland wearing
a kilt no because they also distinguish
between how men wear clothes and women
wear clothes in scotland too
it's just that men wear different
clothes than men in america
it's the most idiotic thing people are
like well yeah back in roman times men
were togas you understand those were
basically just dresses yes
and women were a different form of
clothing at the time women and men were
distinguishable by dress they have
always been distinguishable by dress in
virtually every human culture
and noting that men wore fluffier stuff
in the 16th century in britain does not
change the fact that women wore
completely different clothing in the
16th century in britain
right this is a category error you
morons to suggest
that because men wore something like a
kilt in scotland
that if you transferred over to america
would look more feminine therefore a man
wearing a skirt in america in 2020
is is just the same in the male female
paradigm
as a man wearing a kilt in scotland in
is insane and idiotic and ridiculous on
its face and we all
know that hey pretending that men
dressing like women is not about
feminizing men is ridiculous
because they are overtly celebrating the
fact that style is
that styles is feminizing masculinity so
this is all a big gaslighting effect
right
the left will do this the left routine
is this look how important and magical
it is that harry styles is wearing a
dress
he's subversively undermining
masculinity by bringing the
by bringing the effect of femininity to
the masculine and that's real
masculinity isn't a dude wearing a dress
and then people on the right are like
yes men wearing dresses does undermine
masculinity by making it more feminine
and that is a bad thing
and then folks on the left don't respond
by saying well why is it a bad thing to
feminize masculinity because then they
would lose the argument because
masculinity has very many good things
and ought to be upheld instead what the
left does is this weird gaslighting shut
up routine where they say how dare you
say that wearing that men wearing
dresses undermines masculinity
you said you on the left you said that
wearing a dress undermines masculinity
that is the whole point
of putting people on the cover of
magazines who are men
wearing dresses okay so here's the
bottom line
there are a lot of conservatives i know
who listen to this sort of stuff and
they go well
why aren't we talking about political
races why aren't we talking about why
aren't we talking about tax rates why
aren't we talking about policy
this stuff matters it matters because
these are fundamental ideas to the
the preservation of a civilization boys
and girls are different
boys and girls are different it is
important to inculcate in your children
that boys and girls are different and
any parent who fails to inculcate in a
boy that manliness is
a good thing and that responsible
manliness helps build civilization
any person any parent does not teach
their girls
that femininity meaning the protection
of hearth and home in a different way
than masculinity
is a good thing any person who doesn't
teach their girls that is not doing
their kid any favors
and they are undermining the
civilizational compact between men and
women that exist based on biology in
virtually every human culture
and the left knows that they can't win
this argument because biology cuts
directly against them science cuts
directly against them
so instead they just confuse it instead
they just play these stupid semantic
little games where they say that
masculinity and femininity are
interchangeable and if you say no they
say
how dare you how dare you it's
it's absurd and it's ridiculous and we
shouldn't be shy about discussing these
issues because the left certainly isn't
shy about discussing these issues the
left will
put these in public schools right the
left will will tell your kindergartner
that real men wear dresses and then
you'll be explaining to a five-year-old
why real men do not wear dresses
and and i don't feel that that is an
acceptable ramification
of our cultural discussion is that
you're supposed to shut up because it's
offensive and rude
for you to say that boys and girls are
different but it is inoffensive
and groundbreaking to treat as
completely
without debate that men and women are
exactly the same
in every respect except that men suffer
from toxic masculinity that must be bred
out of them
by wearing 17th century fluffy dresses
on the cover of oak
the answer to that is no and i'm glad
all y'all
really enjoy your harry styles music and
harry styles he's a free man living in a
western country by the way a west
defended
by quite masculine men as a general rule
okay that is
congratulations to harry styles you can
enjoy his music i'm not saying don't
pick up his cds
i'm not saying don't listen to his music
i'm not saying don't watch the movies
he's in
all i'm saying is that when you put out
there an argument that men ought to act
like women and that this is a good thing
you're doing something that undermines
and tears at the fabric of not only
civilization but of families it turns
out the fabric of child rearing and
child raising and everybody
with half a brain knows this and don't
be silenced by people who just tell you
that it's rude to talk about it while
simultaneously demanding
that you put on the cramer aids ribbon
or they're going to
or they're going to club you about the
head for not celebrating that which you
don't find worthy of celebration
okay so meanwhile in actual news covet
continues
to uh to blight the land and the
responses of various political figures
continues
to not be particularly useful so bill de
blasio announced yesterday that they are
closing the schools in new york despite
evidence is perfectly obvious at this
point that schools are not cheap vectors
of transmission does not matter they're
shutting down the schools anyway because
all the political incentives are aligned
to shut things down
even if there's no actual evidence
suggesting that things ought to be shut
down
we said we would make health and safety
the priority
we said we would hold this standard that
was part of how we convinced
everyone that it would be safe to come
into the schools
now we did expect our schools to be safe
the only way i differ with usa
is not unexpected that our schools are
safe we expected them to be safe
we've been very very impressed by the
work everyone's done
they're extraordinarily safe but that
said
we set a standard we asked everyone to
trust it and believe in it
it's important to keep consistency with
that okay
first of all i love bill de blasio
talking about consistency his consistent
standard has been yell at the jews
while suggesting systemic racism is
responsible for upticks of covet and
every other racial minority
so the captain consistency over here has
been like let's have giant riots and
looting in the middle of fifth avenue
that's totally fine with copen but also
you can't have a family gathering
captain consistency over here i love
when he says that um
we set a standard our standard makes no
sense but we have to hold to our
standard now
shutting down the schools good luck to
parents by the way i hope that you've
enjoyed that two weeks of schooling in
new york that you got
i hope that it went really really well
for you meanwhile
joe biden is uh is out there still
maintaining that he has a plan it must
be wonderful being joe biden at this
point not having to have a plan but
getting to blame trump for every bad
thing that is happening
uh he said some very bizarre things
yesterday in front of his cardboard
his cardboard displacing office of the
president-elect there is no office of
the president's elect as we've noted
going all the way back to 2008 when
barack obama
actually created placards that said
office of the president elect that is
not the way that works
in any case joe biden said that the
vaccine is coming and i trust the
vaccine because fauci says the vaccine
is good he says people only question the
vaccine because of trump
which is a weird take considering your
vice president your vice presidential
candidate
kamala harris openly said that she would
not take the vaccine
if trump said to take it so i feel like
the undermining of vaccines and and
taking vaccines
uh that's actually been your party joe
um but i'm i'm glad that now you're on
board that's exciting news
funny how you switch from i'm a little
wary about vaccines your vice president
saying that
uh two vaccines are the most wonderful
thing and trump is the only person
obstructing them when he's the one who
created the program to develop them in
the first place
here's joe biden being a tool the only
reason people question the vaccine now
is because of donald trump
that's the reason why people are
questioning the vaccine because all the
things he says and doesn't say whether
is it truthful is it not truthful the
exaggerations
i think we're on a clear path now we're
on a clear path where the international
community and national leaders
uh in the scientific community have
focused on these two vaccines
they appear to be ready for prime time
ready to be used and if that and
continues along those roads i would take
the vaccine
okay so that old codger is going to be
curing kovitz that's exciting
stuff and then of course he saved some
more blame for trump
right that trump is refusing to
coordinate and it's gonna get a lot of
people killed uh no
it no sorry not true okay the fact is
that apparently
biden is receiving some sort of national
security briefing today so
um yeah here's biden trying to blame
everything on trump as per our usual
arrangement
what do you see as the biggest threat to
your transition right now given
president trump's unprecedented attempt
to obstruct and delay a smooth transfer
of power
more people may die if we don't
coordinate
if we have to wait until january 20th to
start that planning
it puts us behind over a month month and
a half
and so it's important that it be done
that there be coordination
now now or as rapidly as we can get that
done
okay so again everything is trump's
fault meanwhile the media pushing the
idea that if you're a republican you're
more likely to get coveted because
you're an idiot
so it is it is very odd how the the
virus pretty much affects everybody
and that if you are more careful uh
there is a lower likelihood that you're
going to get a severe strain of the
virus and if you are
or a severe case of the virus and if you
are less careful then you are probably
going to
have a higher chance of getting it
nonetheless here is cnn declaring that
president trump and every republican uh
those people are responsible for their
own coveted cases
they hosted a south dakota nurse uh who
then proceeded to explain
that people are dying in south dakota
while declaring that covet is not real
and this is of course because of
president trump as opposed to the huge
number of people who died in new york
who thought presumably coveted was real
and also died it turns out the virus
doesn't care what you think because
the virus is not in fact a woke
mind-reading tool
i think the hardest thing to watch is
that people are still
looking for something else and they want
a magic answer
and they don't want to believe that
coveted is real and the reason i tweeted
what i did
is it wasn't one particular patient it's
just a culmination of so many people
and their last dying words are
um this can't be happening it's not real
and when they should be
spending time face timing their families
they're filled with anger and hatred and
it just made me really sad the other
night
and um i just can't believe that those
are gonna be their last
thoughts and words i'm glad this is uh
cnn's narrative i mean we by the way we
also heard stories
uh a little bit earlier before the
election about people whose last dying
words were things like i hope trump
loses or something it turns out people
have all sorts of weird
ideas uh when they are on their
deathbeds but cnn apparently only is
interested in featuring one type of
particular story okay
meanwhile joe biden is laying forth his
economic
plan so in the in the final days of
president trump's first term depending
on what happens here
joe biden is laying forth his economic
plans his economic plans suck
now let's be frank about this if joe
biden ends up as the president-elect of
the united states if he ends up taking
office in january
then joe biden might be the luckiest cat
on planet earth
uh not just because he presumably would
have been declared the winner but also
because if the republicans win the
senate joe biden is going to get the
benefit of operation warp speed he's
going to be handed a vaccine that will
be widely available by march and april
which means that the economy is going to
boom it means that the v shaped recovery
that started under president trump will
continue
it means the economy is going to spike
and because he will have a republican
senate joe biden will have no way of
stopping the economy
from growing right he'll have wanted to
put forth all of these crappy proposals
raising taxes and increasing regulations
and all this
and he'll have very little ability to
actually implement that you want to know
why the stock market jumped on election
night the reason the stock market jumped
after election night
is because there was an assumption that
republicans were going to keep the
senate which is why those georgia senate
races are really important but
this does put joe biden in particularly
rich
in a particularly rich political area
meaning that for joe biden
all he has to do is continue to sit in
the basement and just reap the rewards
of trump's economic plan and trump's
vaccines
and then the media will credit him right
so that's a wonderful thing
but he's at least going to pay lip
service to all of his
party's most idiotic economic plans so
yesterday he gave a speech on the
economy which basically amounted to
trump is a big bad mean orange man
at some point you would figure that the
specter of trump will will suddenly
just dissipate but never i mean barack
obama was still blaming george w bush
seven years into his term so
you can imagine that that's exactly what
joe biden will be doing as well so joe
biden says
he wants to restructure the tax
structure we need a fairer tax structure
where people at the top pay more which
is insane considering the people at the
top pay literally all net taxes in the
united states
that means taxes that are that are paid
after you receive government benefits
people
in the top one percent are paying the
vast bulk of those taxes people in the
top one percent are paying a highly
disproportionate share of the taxes
it's funny the same people who will
suggest that america's rich are not
paying their fair share
and also say that norway is wonderful
neglect the fact that norway and denmark
and sweden
all these places have incredibly
regressive tax systems compared to the
united states america has an incredibly
progressive graduated tax system where
people at the top get absolutely
shellacked and if you're not earning all
that much money or if you're middle
class you're not paying very high taxes
if you go over to europe everybody is
paying high taxes in any case here is
joe biden just lying and saying we don't
have a fair tax system
which is code 4 i want to seize more
money from people who earn a lot
it's time to reward work not just wealth
in america
we're going to have a fair tax structure
to make sure the wealthiest among us and
corporations pay their fair share
our plan will create millions of good
paying union jobs
in manufacturing building the vehicles
products technologies that are gonna
we're gonna need for the future to
compete with the rest of the world
from autos to our stockpiles we're going
to
buy american okay so um let's let's just
be real about this when he talks about
how work must be rewarded
family income grew under donald trump in
the first three years
of his administration faster and more
completely in total than under eight
years of barack obama
and the people who are mostly making
that money were people in the middle and
the bottom
end of the spectrum you know there's
actually faster income growth among
people who are at the lower end of the
spectrum than in people at the top
end of the spectrum it doesn't matter
joe biden is going to continue to push
these crappy plans meanwhile joe biden
has another plan
and this one again is incredibly
regressive so first of all
it's hilarious that joe biden continues
to suggest that america's tax system is
regressive when it is actually quite
progressive also he wants to push
what sounds like the most regressive
policy
prescription that i can think of he
wants to simply cancel student loan debt
now this is idiotic in all respects
we'll get to this in just one i'll
explain in just one second here's joe
biden saying this yesterday
the student loan forgiveness figure in
your plan would you take executive
action to achieve it
it does figure in my plan i've laid out
in detail for example
the uh the legislation passed by the
democratic house
calls for immediate ten thousand dollar
forgiveness of student loan just holding
people up
they're in real trouble they're having
to make choices between paying their
student loan and paying the rent those
kinds of decisions
it should be done immediately okay so he
wants to just come in and relieve
student loan debt so a few points here
one if you paid your bills you're a
sucker
right i paid my wife's medical school
bills i paid my law school bills
my parents helped me out with college we
all took on debt and we all paid off
that debt in order to pay off our debts
and we did so in the assumption that
that was going to be a way of investing
in the future
and here comes joe biden saying
basically you're suckers because not
only did you pay off your debt
now the taxpayer is going to assume
everybody else's debt which means that
you're going to have to pay for some
jackasses jackass antifa students degree
in queer studies
so i'm a sucker you're a sucker if
you're a tax payer you're so if you're a
high school student
if you're a high school grad and you
didn't go to college you're a serious
sucker
because you could have gone for free and
then just had joe biden alleviate that
not only that
you're not going to have to pay because
the taxes are going to come you're going
to have to pay
for that college student to get that
ridiculous degree
and what this really is is a subsidy to
a university system that indoctrinates
kids in stupidity
there are two types of degrees that come
out of college systems and there's the
type of degree where you actually learn
something my wife was pre-med right so
she was in psychobiology that is a hard
science
if you look at the hard sciences science
tech engineering math right the stem
fields
those are actual degrees with actual
skill sets then they're what we ucla
used to call the north campus degrees
right they're the english majors and the
poli sci majors i'll speak about poli
science because i was a policy major it
was useless crap
the only reason that you got a poli sci
major was that you could go to law
school or brag that you got a polysider
group from ucla without any concomitant
skill set it was a scam
designed to give you a degree these are
degree mills that is what these that is
what these colleges are they are
designed as sort
as sorting mechanisms as feeder
mechanisms right the idea is that
employers are i believe banned by
federal law from giving things like iq
tests in order to determine
whether or not you're smart enough to be
hired so instead we have an entire
ridiculous and backwards and convoluted
system where you're supposed to incur
tens or hundreds of thousands of dollars
in debt to basically take an iq test
which is all that
that a degree from a college basically
is right because you take an sat which
is a low-level iq test or an act same
sort of thing
and then you get funneled into a college
then the college weeds out people who
are not particularly hard-working
and then you get the degree and all an
employer an employer learns from that is
not that you have a marketable skill set
they learn that you are quote unquote
smart right this is why if you have
harvard on your
on your diploma even if you majored in
something really stupid you're probably
more likely to get a job than if you
have junior college on your diploma and
you measure in something not
particularly stupid
because everybody sort of understands
unless you're majoring in science
technology engineering math
then you are basically learning not much
of anything you're just going there to
get the degree
and then that sorting mechanism can be
used to get you into
into a job somewhere we'd be much better
off pushing apprenticeship program so i
have an alternative proposal instead of
rewarding these colleges with taxpayer
money
because again when you wipe out the debt
taxpayers pick it up that's all that
means
there's no such thing as free college
there's just taxpayers paying for your
crappy major one of the reasons that i
like the idea of private institutions
providing the loans for colleges as
opposed to the federal government
backing them
is because private institutions
sometimes take a look at your degree and
determine whether they think you're
going to pay back
the thing about a degree is that it is
not foreclosable
when a bank gives you a mortgage on a
house they make an assessment one are
you gonna pay back the debt two if you
don't pay back the debt can they seize
the property
right it's secured it's a secured loan
education is an unsecured loan
there is no collateral they can seize if
you stop paying back your debt so what
banks typically do
is they look at what you're getting a
degree in if you are getting a degree
from harvard law then they can assume
that you're going to pay back the debt
because you're probably going to get a
high
flying law job that makes you a couple
hundred grand a year start
right that's a better bet than if you
are getting a theater major
at wesleyan right that might be harder
to get a loan for in the private sector
which is right the federal government
comes in and guarantees all of these
loans
which is idiotic because now they are
subsidizing a bunch of crappy majors at
a bunch of colleges that are just there
to indoctrinate
you into wokism okay so this should all
be privatized in the first place but i
have another idea if we are going to
actually forgive
these debts how about this how instead
of having the taxpayers forgive the
debts how about
if you have a useless major and you're
not earning a lot of money and you
actually have serious loan debt because
you took out a bunch of loans to do that
theater major
in lesbian dance theory over at wesleyan
how about this
how about wesleyan has to eat the cost
because wesleyan was in on the scam
wesleyan knew you weren't going to get a
job in lesbian dance
after you got your degree how about they
who helped perpetuate the scam they have
to eat the cost
that would end the scam this grift right
quick wouldn't it
but joe biden has no intention of doing
that because of course these colleges
are churning out democratic voters
they are a way of indoctrinating people
into ideologies that joe biden favors
this is an anti-blue collar program it
doesn't help high school grads it does
not care for people
who don't feel like wasting four years
of their lives and hundreds of thousands
of dollars
at a college to earn a degree in in crap
it doesn't help people who have already
paid their debts
and it subsidizes people who are in the
least profitable and
least useful majors okay so this is a
very regressive program that joe biden
is pushing
naturally uh but this is the the left i
mean the left-wing democratic party
is now basically a coalition of the of
the
intersectionally aggrieved and the woke
white people that that's what the
democratic party coalition is well good
luck with that in the future
okay meanwhile the media are trying to
pave the ground going forward for a
biden administration
they're trying to somehow create the
narrative that biden ought to get back
in the iran deal so one of the signal
achievements of the trump administration
was getting out of the iran deal
which put the iranian mullahs behind the
eight ball economically and put them in
a very difficult situation because
all of their ability to access world
markets basically collapsed they've been
in a state of economic collapse for
years it has prevented them
from achieving the kind of the the kind
of
forward thrusting aggressive terrorist
backing action that they had been
pursuing in places like yemen or in
lebanon or in syria
so that was very it was very successful
and it also happened to result in an
anti-iranian alliance between israel
and the uae and the fact of saudi arabia
egypt jordan
okay all of that was very good so now
the media have to come up with some
excuse
why joe biden should be able to cut a
new deal with the iranian government
which is on the ropes
so the way that they are now crafting
this narrative
is that donald trump is going to nuke
iran
right that donald trump is creating
danger in iran
and the iran has created new nuclear
facilities
that trump wants to pursue militants and
the only alternative is for joe biden to
come in and sign an agreement with the
iranians
so they are pushing a headline
suggesting that trump sought options for
attacking iran to stop its growing
nuclear program this is the article
from the new york times okay now here's
what the article says and you'll see how
it doesn't agree with the headline
president trump asked senior advisors in
an oval office meeting on thursday
whether he had options to take action
against iran's main nuclear site in the
coming weeks
the meeting occurred today after
international inspectors reported a
significant increase in the country's
stockpile of nuclear material for
current and former u.s officials said on
monday
a range of senior advisors dissuaded the
president from moving ahead with the
military strike
the advisors including vice president
pence secretary of state pompeo
christopher miller the acting defense
secretary and general milly the chairman
of the joint chiefs
warned a strike against iran's
facilities could easily escalate into a
broader conflict in the last weeks of
trump's presidency
trump asked his top national security
officials what options were available
and how to respond after pompeo and
milly described the potential risks
officials left the meeting believing a
missile
attack inside iran was off the table
okay so in other words
trump said what are our options on
nuclear facilities they said well we
shouldn't do anything military and trump
said okay
the headline is trump considered
military attack because the media are
now attempting to craft a narrative
where the
only alternative to joe biden making
concessions to a terrorist regime
is war we did this already right we did
this back in 2009 2010
when the obama administration crafted a
narrative and then threw it out there
for
stenographers to push right jeffrey
goldberg to push ben rhodes bragged
openly that this is what they were doing
ben rhodes who is then deputy national
security adviser bragged openly
at the obama administration had crafted
a lie around iran which is that there
were only two alternatives
full-fledged war with iran and
submitting to iran's will
and it turned out that was crap because
trump came in and did a third way and
was very successful in containing iran
he killed off their terrorist leader
kasim soleimani
he he created an alliance against them
that checked their power he drove their
economy into the ground right all of
that was very good so now the media are
trying to revive the same narrative
obama pushed the first time that the
only alternatives are open warfare with
the iranian government
or making concessions to the iranian
government don't fall for it it is a
media crafted narrative and it is
garbage
but the media will shift on a dime when
it comes to foreign policy anyway
there is a certain humor in the fact
that the media are very upset that trump
is now talking about a troop drawdown in
iraq and afghanistan
and this prompted cnn's briana keeler to
rip trump for this
say this is very bad now i'm old enough
to remember when barack obama pledged a
troop drawdown in iraq did it
and created isis i'm old enough to
remember when he pledged to draw down in
afghanistan and was it and was
negotiating with the taliban
you know what the media said then what a
forward-thinking foreign policy leader
now
cnn's like how dare trump do this exact
same thing joe biden and barack obama
pushed
who does this who dropped something like
this in the lap
of an incoming president no one
other than donald trump i think what
he's trying to do is go through his
bucket list quite honestly
and saying you know he promised to get
out of these wars
and he was going to do it and uh jake
tapper
but gloria can we just be clear on that
he's not getting out of these wars
that's right i mean
he's right he's just like he's ending it
he's just he's just handicapping the
next guy who has to deal with it i mean
who who is going who would do something
like this who would say for example in
the last month of an administration
push forward a u.n resolution completely
upending all previous conventional
wisdom
about israeli claims to for example
jerusalem who would do that by
abstaining from a un resolute oh wait
barack obama did that
in the last month just as a parting shot
at bibi netanyahu and and the jews
so yeah spare me spare me god th
these media folks they gotta they gotta
be replaced go over to dailywire.com
get a true narrative join a bunch of
other services stop
cut your cable enough of this all right
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2020. georgia
discovers 2600 missing votes from a
pro-trump county
experts tell biden to cancel
thanksgiving and dr fauci
tells president trump to concede for
public health
check it out on the michael knowles show